ça a été compliqué dès le début on a eu
des conditions très forte qu'on
s'attendait pas à voir les conditions si
forte que ça on a d'ailleurs on a des
une semaine la première semaine on a
chaviré c'est le bateau s'est retourné
on s'est retrouvé à nager autour et a
fallu redresser c'est vrai c'est assez
bien
une semaine après une semaine après il
ya eu encore une tempête où on a encore
chaviré pendant la nuit
donc c'est c'est ça a été vraiment très
très musclé pendant la moitié du
parcours
ensuite ça a été des vents portants qui
nous ont qui nous ont bien aidés on a
beaucoup aimé je peux vous dire que on a
des bras rallonger comme des cons et des
muscles le sais pas mais en tout cas on
va pas grossi on n'a pas voici et puis
ça s'est passé plutôt bien jusque
jusqu'à l'arrivée aujourd'hui j'ai pas
eu de doute souvent dans cette percée
quand on en parle à des gens qui
pleurent
heureusement j'en ai marre j'en veux
plus moi je me suis dit on est parti
pour ça c'était une volonté on était à
notre place moi j'étais à ma place et
j'ai pas eu des moments de doute
j'avais un moment envie que ça s'arrête
parce que parce qu'au bout de cinquante
jours bon c'est bien ça ressemble un peu
sont là mais pas de doute qu'une envie
d'arriver qu'une certitude c'est qu'il
fallait au bout pour dire merci à tous
ceux qu'ils ont fait contre très
heureuse à accomplir et philips des
filles
un beau défi c'est un défi à la fois
bien sûr sportif mais défi humain aussi
parce que vivre deux sur trois quatre
mètres carrés
c'est pas toujours facile donc il a
fallu lui mettre du sien et chacun est
donc ensuite un défi à la taille de
l'atlantique
bon moi j'étais un peu un récidiviste
mai
voilà puis moi j'aime un défi aussi
c'est que je suis à tannay maladie de
parkinson
donc du coup je voulais démontrer et ça
fait longtemps que je pense je veux
démontrer jeter bon que c'est pas parce
qu'on a atteint d'une maladie
neurodégénérative qu'on ne peut pas
faire de grandes choses et ça et ça
c'est je voulais prouver mais bien sûr
il faut aussi il faut bouger alors je
dis aux oraux qui sont atteints à mal
des partisans de bouger souvent ils
rigolent du matin nous notre problème
c'est qu'on bouge tout le temps gédéon
bon je te prends comme une idée reçue
que les fraises oui d'accord mais là je
demande de bouger sur des mouvements
volontaires